ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States thanks
for you to pay for my blood along now
the whole thing is breezily knows the
life
thanks the President of Mexico why
register president robert muller has
assembled a grand jury in the russia
probe do you have any comment unfair I'm
supposed to be tried by a jury of my
peers where they going to find 12
presidents who are allegedly being
blackmailed by Putin why does your
immigration plan place so much
importance on the ability to speak
English if you want to live here you
need to talk English very good as a
president who English great me no job
good is important for jobs do nice and
with good American like local milk
people so true so true how do you
respond to reports at the White House is
in chaos no there's no chaos and that's
why tonight's theme is chaos you just
said there's no cab right that's why
tonight's theme is order I have a new
chief of staff general John Kelly a very
tough guy and I trust the general he
gets me the best car insurance rates on
earth which as we all know save some
time
Skelly has done such incredible work
with deportation this guy tears families
apart and I can't wait to see what he'll
do to mine you want you want him to tear
your family apart
what no maybe I don't know some of them
our theme is chaos I thought it was
order you're out of order I'm the
president
chaos believe it what's wrong